anyone noticed yet today that my voice
sounds a little different is it sound a
little different to you little sexier a
little lower thanks a lot
there's a reason for that I haven't
actually felt well today you bastards
yeah ring spin but when I say I'm sick
what this is my lead into I have a
terminal illness you don't know where
I'm going with this do you all right
well anyway it isn't want one because
it's basically you know I I just have I
don't some kind of virus or something
and I last night I was up all night
really sore throat I woke up today achy
just don't feel well come to work as the
show must go on or they'll fire my ass
so got through most of the day and then
this is true just about I don't know
like two hours or two and a half hours
before we tape tonight's show just just
a little while ago I decided I'm just
gonna go see a doctor so I went to the
NBC Medical Center here in the building
to visit the doctor and I know my fans
worry about me
so I just pretend and so so I asked
someone to grab a handheld camera and
come along with me while I visited the
NBC doctor and we just shot this and and
well here's what happened this is Tanya
Benison she's the associate medical
director here at NBC Universal Medical
Services General Electric subsidiary
medical unit of GE NBC Universal now a
Viacom distributor thanks for seeing me
the last two days I felt not great then
last night
feverish sore throat drank a lot of
nyquil a lot of nyquil and woke up with
my pants around my ankles
actually feel better I felt better sort
of the guy I was with no I don't feel
busy I mostly I just feel sort of
uninvolved in the political process I
don't really care about who wins do you
feel comfortable talking to about the
stomach stuff that was going on like was
it nausea diarrhea like what was uh what
was that symptom you really want me to
talk about diarrhea in television I like
the word diarrhea I think you'd like to
pour diarrhea to you I can talk about
diarrhea you are an amazing woman do you
ever find yourself talking to patients
and they mention it that they've had
diarrhea and you start laughing maybe
witness that's sad when all the joy goes
out of your life because in in great
shape I think I'm an amazing male
specimen does ever say that anymore like
you're an amazing male specimen do you
think so maybe in jest if this somehow
could all end with you saying well
you're an amazing male specimen and I
had that on camera that would be great
but that's you decide right she'll go to
the examining room let's do that okay
let's start with taking your temperature
all right mm-hmm
this will be very exciting
right on 75 you're actually cold a lot
of wax in there yeah well how do we get
it out I mean I I try I'll have a how
bad is it
you know your canals like this you're
almost a hundred percent included with
surprise you can hear anything
always works that one ready gagra what
are you feeling there I was feeling
first of all in lymph nodes glands made
me tender yeah all right
there's a tattoo there it says REO
Speedwagon rules 78 I thought that band
was gonna go the distance oh my god
all right lungs are clear
I want as much medication as I could
possibly have really do you have you
know sometimes you hear about like those
a cool Tylenol that they only sell in
Sweden that has codeine in it a little
bit of cocaine right you know in
marijuana is that something that I mean
I know yeah can I have it anyway badly
do you need to listen to my heart
frontal region I don't but I'm happy to
would you like to listen to my heart
won't you listen to my heart what if I
don't like what I hear you're gonna like
what you hear like a tank hey you
getting a good read on that a little bit
you haven't said anything for a while so
completely unrelated to your sore throat
do you have much of our prolapse or
anything
what's the prolapse it's a one of the
valves in the hearts just a little bit
floppy I just came here to shoot me son
totally I came here to shoot like a
silly little I've got a cold and we're
gonna just screw around and you're
telling me something real but it's
nothing you don't have a murmur anything
okay I have a floppy heart a live inner
rage I'm Irish Catholics talk alright
I'm worried we don't do well in the long
run we're not people that live a long
time would you like to see me do some
push-ups right now little petite what do
you think I'm pretty good bill yeah
really fantastic I think maybe in
replace male specimen you think maybe
I'm a male specimen now you say I think
you're a male specimen it means my
gender is a little in question yeah
thank you
this is the sort of wimpy sudafed cuz we
can't really get the real sudafed
anymore because of the crystal meth
problem so I can't make crystal meth out
of this
that's okay though you didn't gonna be
okay thanks I'm okay in the floppy heart
I mean that was a bit of a bump in the
road what I thought was gonna be just a
quick fun remote I need a new heart if
anyone's watching okay and I think
you'll live at least a 65 65 yeah Wow I
give me four more years Conan O'Brien is
a fantastic male specimen
[Applause]
make me come back you got to see this
the great throwdini